I'm like everybody else it's there's a
lot of stress but Mark Cuban is
remaining optimistic as the corona virus
pandemic continues the billionaire
entrepreneur isn't concerned about
America's eventual economic rebound it
is the absolute best time in the history
of starting businesses to start a
business house called Cuban on next
stars digital original coronavirus house
calls this weekend says despite the
recession new business startups have a
good opportunity for success if you're
starting from scratch right now you
already have a good feel for all the new
rules post pandemic you already have a
good feel for it you know your thoughts
on how to incorporate social distancing
if that's applicable work from home if
that's Apple this week the National
Bureau of Economic Research said the
u.s. entered a recession
earlier this year ending a
record-setting 128 month period of
growth and now Mark Cuban says personal
financial responsibility is more
important than ever as the consumer you
know really looked and really make sure
you understand your personal financial
situation and whatever you need to do
now is the time to start budgeting as
every state is now starting to reopen
its economy Cuban urges patients we have
imperfect information as it pertains to
the virus and so it's hard to make the
right decision and we're not going to
know till after the fact whether we were
right or wrong remaining optimistic in
the face of uncertainty
I'm jack reuler now back to you